My name is Dr. Watson. And for many years, I was a good friend of the famous detective Sherlock Holmes.
Holmes and I were eating breakfast when suddenly, Holmes said to me,...
..."I have to go to a place called King's Pyland."
"A horse has disappeared from there and the police can't find it."
"Why is this horse so important, Holmes?", I asked.
"Because Watson,",...
...Holmes explained,...
..."it is going to run in a big race called the Wessex Cup."
"If it wins, a lot of people who have bet large sums of money on it will win a great deal."
"There are also people who don't want it to win."
Holmes paused, and then he said,...
..."Watson, did you read in the newspaper about John Straker being murdered?"
"Yes, most newspapers reported the murder."
"Well Watson, John Straker was the man who was responsible for looking after the horse,...
...training, and exercising it."
We left the house and went to where the body of John Straker had been found.
Suddenly, Colonel Ross whispered something in my ear.
"Why is Mr. Holmes on his hands and knees?",...
...he asked.
Before I could reply, Holmes exclaimed,...
..."Hello! What's this?"
He held up a tiny piece of wood.
"It's a match, half-burned here in the mud.",...
...Holmes answered.
"I must have missed it, Mr. Holmes. I'm sorry.",...
...the inspector apologized.
"Don't feel bad. I was actually looking for it.",...
...Holmes told him.
"You expected to find a match?",...
...the inspector asked, very surprised.
Holmes gave me one of his thin smiles.
"Yes.",...
...he said.
"You know, Watson, being a detective is like playing the best game in the world."
"It's an occupation full of surprises and this game has just started."